Traductor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Todo comenzó cuando yo era muy pequeño.
Cuando mis amigos
salían a montar en bicicleta
yo me iba a la casa de mi abuela,
que tenía un perro muy pequeño
que se llamaba Llorón.
Yo llegaba con mis salchichas,
mis chuches...
Me encantaba ir a casa de mi abuela.
Rápidamente me di cuenta de que
me iba a dedicar a trabajar
o a estar en contacto con el perro
durante el resto de mi vida.
A los 18 años monté una escuela canina
y un hotel canino de lujo.
Después me di cuenta de que
lo que me gustaba realmente,
aparte de estar con los perros,
era la seguridad y proteger,
con lo cual monté una empresa
de seguridad un tanto atípica,
porque era una empresa de seguridad
exclusivamente dedicada a trabajar
con perros y vigilantes de seguridad.
Hacíamos binomios totalmente
indivisibles e indestructibles.
Después, en el año 2009,
estaba en un certamen internacional
y haciendo una pequeña exhibición
con mis perros de seguridad,
se me acercó una mujer y me dijo,
mirándome a los ojos,
que necesitaba que le entrenase
el perro para poder repeler
las continuas agresiones que estaba
sufriendo por parte de su expareja.
Inmediatamente empecé a darle vueltas.
Empecé a ver que el trabajo convencional
del perro de seguridad
no era el trabajo que debíamos
emprender con esta mujer.
Ya estábamos acostumbrados a trabajar
en circunstancias de alto riesgo
con perros de seguridad.
Empezamos a indagar sobre un instinto,
que está en la naturaleza
y que está poco comprendido:
el instinto de protección.
Y el proyecto Pepo se basó
en ese instinto de protección.
En el primer momento
pretendíamos que el Pepo estuviese
para cubrir ese espacio-tiempo crítico
entre que la víctima
se encuentra con su agresor
y activa las medidas telemáticas
que le ofrece el Gobierno,
que son las pulseras, el GPS.
En el mejor de los casos
son entre 5 y 8 minutos
en los que víctima de violencia de género
se encuentra de cara con su agresor.
Ahí estaba el Pepo.
Desde el minuto cero
empezamos a ver que las virtudes
que aportaba el perro eran increíbles.
Eran unas virtudes colaterales.
Veíamos que ya estaba la protección,
pero el perro les daba libertad,
les daba ganas de salir a la calle,
las empoderaba.
Un Pepo es un perro que reúne
unas características especiales:
tiene que ser social, equilibrado,
gozar de una impregnación exquisita.
Cuando me refiero a impregnación
es la fase que comprende
desde la tercera semana de edad
hasta aproximadamente
los 7-8 meses de vida del perro:
todo lo que oiga, vea, sienta o padezca
lo va a relacionar con estímulos
que le sucedan en un futuro
y no va a desarrollar taras
ni fobias hacia ellos.
Son perros súper sociales,
tienen que tener
un sentimiento de justicia
y un instinto de protección.
Nosotros a estos perros
les colocamos una dotación especial:
un arnés que, a partir de ahora,
va a ser el catalizador de la protección.
El perro no decide
quién es o no es el agresor,
lo decide la usuaria,
o la víctima de violencia de género,
que apoyándose, haciendo un movimiento
mecánico que entrenamos en este arnés,
el perro entra en modo protección
y no deja a nadie acercarse a ella.
También llevan unos bozales especiales,
especialmente diseñados para repeler
agresiones sin causar heridas graves.
Empezamos a consensuar los entrenamientos
con psicólogos y psiquiatras.
Empezamos a hacer desarrollos tácticos.
¿Qué son desarrollos tácticos?
Situaciones que simulan
la realidad, sin serlo,
y que ayudan tanto a la mujer y al perro
a desenvolverse en situaciones reales.
Imagínense una circunstancia:
"No quiero que vuelvas a bajar a la calle.
¿Con esos pantalones ajustados?"
Son palabras duras,
pero hay que recrearlas,
porque a través del hipervínculo
que creamos con el perro
aflora este instinto de protección.
Hoy en día tenemos 50 usuarias
que ya disfrutan de sus Pepos.
Estamos formando a otras 10.
La formación que reciben
estas usuarias es exquisita.
No vayan a pensar que es cuestión
de coger y darles el perro, no.
Ellas pasan por un curso
de aproximadamente 150 horas
que las hace adiestradoras.
Es más, muchas se dedican
ya al adiestramiento,
a trabajar: se ganan la vida
adiestrando perros.
Les damos otro curso de 20 horas,
que es el que obliga la ley
a los vigilantes de seguridad
para poder llevar perros de seguridad.
Pues muchas son vigilantes de seguridad.
Muchas de nuestras usuarias
ya son vigilantes de seguridad.
Luego les damos otro curso de 20 horas
sobre perros de violencia de género.
Y ellas son partícipes en este curso.
Hay unas palabras que nos han hecho volar.
Una eminencia en psiquiatría
de uno de los mejores hospitales de España
dijo, conocedor del proyecto Pepo,
que ni en 7 años de terapia
conseguía lo que nosotros en 7 días.
Para mí, ver esa sonrisa que tienen
cuando llevan su perro,
es absolutamente indescriptible
lo que siento cuando veo esa sonrisa,
después de estar recuperadas.
Les vamos a poner un vídeo
para que vean cómo funcionan los Pepos.
¿Qué? ¿Con el perro este
yo no voy a poder llegar a ti, o qué?
¿Eh?
(Ladridos)
¿Qué te pasa, eh?
¡Eh!
¿Qué pasa?
Ven aquí.
(Aplausos)
(Fin de los aplausos)
Este es Duque, mi Pepo.
Les voy a contar la historia
de cómo nos conocimos.
Mi historia es como la de cualquier
mujer que se enamora:
conoces a alguien
que es encantador, maravilloso,
todo se le hace poco para ti,
nadie había tenido tantos detalles,
halagos, piropos...
Piensas que pasarás el resto de su vida
con esa persona tan maravillosa,
o al menos es lo que la gente cree.
Pero lo que la gente no sabe es que
cada mañana te despiertas pensando:
¿Por qué se enfadará hoy?
¿Qué excusa tendrá para insultarme,
vejarme y anularme?
¿Saben cuándo dejé de justificar
todos sus empujones y sus malos modales?
Cuando vi que también
lo hacía con mis hijos.
Ahí dije: "Basta".
Denuncié y empezaron los juicios,
las órdenes de protección,
las visitas a los niños,
y después de seis meses
se podía volver a acercar a mí.
No sé si están al tanto de que
esas órdenes de protección caducan.
Cuando mi protección caducó,
él se acercó a mí e intentó matarme,
pero afortunadamente no lo consiguió.
Y empezaron de nuevo los juicios,
las órdenes de alejamiento,
la escolta policial.
Todos los medios que la ley pone a
disposición de las víctimas de género.
Las medidas telemáticas,
esas grandes medidas
que te crean ansiedad,
angustia por todos los fallos técnicos
y de diseño que conllevan.
El aparato, cada vez que sonaba,
no sabía si era porque lo tenía al lado
o porque había perdido cobertura.
Suenan igual.
Vives en el miedo constante,
y les aseguro que es agotador.
Pero después de 8 años te acostumbras
a vivir con esa orden
de alejamiento y ese miedo.
Pero entonces piensas:
"¿Y después de esa orden?
¿Después de que mi protección
vuelva a terminar?
¿Qué será de mí y de mis hijos?
¿Volverá para terminar
lo que un día empezó?"
Ahí conocí el proyecto Pepo.
Perros de protección para víctimas
de violencia de género.
Me costó muchísimo coger
el teléfono y marcar.
Recuerdo que apenas me salía
un hilo de voz,
y al otro lado, Ángel.
Ahí estaba para ayudarme, no lo dudó.
Pasé todas las entrevistas, los filtros,
lo necesario para entrar en el proyecto.
Y empezaron los cursos.
Mi primer curso, rodeada
de un montón de hombres,
a los que ni siquiera podía
mirarles a la cara.
Me sentía pequeñita a su lado.
Me intimaban muchísimo:
eran todos vigilantes de seguridad.
Pero Ángel decía que era una fase
muy importante para mi recuperación.
Y ahí descubrí que seguía
habiendo gente buena.
Pasé por mi primer seminario
de violencia de género.
Allí las mujeres cuentan su experiencia
para ayudar a otras.
Lo pasé fatal; tuve que salir de la sala
porque la angustia no me dejaba respirar.
Todos los recuerdos
se me agolpaban en la mente.
En ese momento, ellas me enseñaron que,
aunque lo veas muy negro, de ahí se sale.
Y ese mismo día tuve
mi primer entrenamiento.
Pude comprobar lo que era tener
protección por parte de un perro.
Él es Tango, un pastor alemán enorme.
Me arrodillé, le abracé,
y Ángel se aceró hacia mí, increpándome,
diciendo barbaridades.
Tango empezó a gruñir,
su pecho se aceleraba cada vez más,
pero a pesar de la situación
no me puse nerviosa.
Me sentí segura.
Después de tantos años había podido
apartar el miedo por un momento.
Al poco tiempo Ángel me presentó
a mi cachorrete de Pepo,
mi futuro gran Pepo.
Teníamos tiempo suficiente
para poder crecer juntos:
me quedaban dos años
de orden de protección.
Y cuando llegó a casa,
fue todo un gran cambio.
Ya no me valía decir que no salía
de casa, tenía que salir sí o sí,
a él había que sacarle,
si no quería encontrar
algún regalito por el suelo.
Entonces, cuando ya estaba en la calle,
ya no era yo la que miraba hacia atrás,
él me avisaba de cualquier ruido,
de cualquier presencia.
Giraba la oreja y me alertaba.
Duque me devolvió las ganas
de hacer cosas nuevas,
de coger el coche y salir de mi barrio,
de conocer sitios a los que antes
era impensable ir sola.
Mis hijos ya no cerraban
la puerta de casa con llave.
El proyecto me cambió la vida,
pero tenía que comprobar si realmente,
después de 16 meses de duro trabajo,
había dado frutos.
Si mi perro me protegería.
¿Y saben? No lo dudó, ni un momento.
Cuando vio que Ángel me miró mal
y se acercó hacia mí, amenazante,
Duque no dejó que se acercara.
Yo ya no estaba sola, él estaba ahí
para evitar que me hicieran daño otra vez.
Él me quitó todos los miedos,
el miedo a salir a la calle,
ir al parque con mis hijos,
o entablar una conversación con extraños.
Me quitó todos los miedos
que te susurran a la espalda
y que te recuerdan
que tu agresor sigue ahí.
Sí, él sigue ahí,
pero yo ya no soy víctima.
Ahora colaboro, soy parte del proyecto.
Colaboro ayudando a otras mujeres que,
como yo llegué en su día,
totalmente hundidas,
con muchos miedos y ninguna autoestima.
Ver cómo un perrete les devuelve
las ganas de vivir, de salir,
de ponerse guapas y comerse el mundo.
No hay palabras que describan
ese sentimiento.
Yo lo viví,
y ahora las ayudo a ellas
a que lo vivan también.
El proyecto nos da seguridad, protección,
confianza en nosotras mismas,
y nos enseña que sigue habiendo gente
que merece la pena conocer.
Duque está siempre conmigo:
en casa, en el trabajo.
Pero hay lagunas legales
que estamos intentando solventar,
puesto que si vamos a algún
centro comercial, cine o sitio público,
no podemos pasar con él,
en ocasiones no nos dejan.
Por ejemplo, ayer
nos impidieron pasar aquí.
Pero estamos luchando
por que nos dejen pasar,
porque nosotras no dejamos
un perro atado a la puerta,
estamos dejando nuestra protección,
nuestra seguridad, nuestra vida.
Y eso lo tenemos muy claro:
queremos seguir vivas,
y si él no pasa, nosotras tampoco.
Poco a poco vamos trabajando
para que más mujeres sigan vivas,
pero para poder ayudarlas
necesitamos financiación.
Hasta ahora todos los recursos han venido
de Ángel y su empresa, altruistamente.
No nos pide nada a cambio.
Ya vamos consiguiendo
colaboradores, poquito a poco.
Pero somos muchas mujeres y muchas más
que empiezan a venir a pedir ayuda,
y no solo eso: comisarías,
psicólogos, asistentes sociales,
e incluso el Instituto de la Mujer
nos derivan casos,
y eso es porque el proyecto funciona.
Se ha corrido la voz.
Pero no podemos hacerlo
todo nosotros solos.
Ya somos 50 mujeres en el proyecto,
50 mujeres que pasamos
de vivir en la oscuridad
para vivir en libertad.
Otras 10 están en formación,
viviéndolo con su cachorro de Pepo,
y hoy, todas nosotras, las 50,
podemos decirles a esas 10
que somos libres gracias
a nuestro compañero de vida.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)